other than that I've put like 40 hours
into po world of course po world the big
thing that has oh yes bro what a [__]
show on Twitter it's crazy cuz like
what's funny is that I taught people who
aren't on Twitter yeah and they're like
well I just played the game I thought it
was kind of cool and I was like you know
there's like a whole [__] storm going on
I think that's most things nowadays but
it's it's making me appreciate or how
isolated Twitter has become in terms of
public discourse like there are a lot of
people who I guess would kind of It kind
of felt like news used to be on Twitter
and discussion used to be on there but
now it seems to be more so that Twitter
is slowly becoming just rage and what
people are angry about and this has been
the peak Peak example of that especially
with the amount of misinformation going
around you you want to know a conspiracy
theory actually uh like think might be
actually happening you heard about like
the dead internet Theory uh I think I
actually I've heard of this oh that
they're all like Bots yeah that's I
think 90% of replies and interactions
you see online are Bots and the more I
browse Twitter the more I'm like wait a
minute let me get my tinf I know we had
an entire episode on conspiracy theories
but I think this one this one I'm just
like yeah yeah the dead internet theory
is the online conspiracy theory that
asserts that the internet now consists
mainly of Bot activity and automatically
generated content that is manipulated by
algorithmic curation and I'm like this
is this is just Twitter to a te I mean
feels that way cuz people you're talking
to are brain dead I mean if it had
that's the thing I actually like
genuinely can't tell if people are brain
dead or if they're are Bots because I
like how can you tell the difference I
think we need to do like a touring test
on all these like accounts bro we need
to see I just think the worst change
they made was basically how Twitter
handles replies and handling paid users
to appear higher up bro when I see a
blue check mark now I'm like are you a
person or are you a bot but it just kind
of ruined it and it made it seem that
man it just made made it a lot worse cuz
it felt like before when uh something
kind of reasonable or an argument was
being made that was more reasonable yeah
uh often you know people would kind of
be like yeah that that makes more sense
it's not it's not inflammatory uh it
would kind of get it would kind of go to
the top and it kind of felt like there
was more discourse whereas now it's more
like okay you have a check mark you you
saying something abhorent gets to the
front yeah or you're you just throwing
around accusations goes to the top or
whatever and well I think the new check
mark on Twitter now is not the Blue Tick
it's the thing next to the Blue Tick
which is like this account is associated
with this legitimate comp what we are
like that's the new one also quote
retweets I think quote retweets is
probably one of the like that becoming a
huge thing became one of the worst
things it's it's it kind of helped in
the start to kind of people who had
turned off replies or were blocking
people it was kind of helpful for
allowing people to kind of call out Bad
actors and then it slowly became this
kind of dunking Trend when now it's all
about ratio started was a fun thing
until every tweet was a ratio yeah you
everyone trying to one up each other
everyone's trying to dunk on it and
you're almost rewarded for spreading
[__] not it doesn't even have to be
like something opinionated that you're
quote retweeting but like you can just
like it can just be like oh I had a nice
day today and then just someone quot
tting with L plus ratio you went outside
but like right or wrong it's just been
absolutely fascinating and also super
depressing just seeing the discourse
around this game where everyone is just
arguing about a different thing and no
one just call yeah so okay so oh my god
there so I had I had heard about this
game coming out before it actually got
released right I should I should have
prepared a dark timeline for you but I
have not played the game I've only seen
images of it okay so this game it's
Pokemon with guns right yeah uh yes for
the lack of better words so this game
kind of comes out of nowhere for example
the trailer starts picking up some steam
two or three days before some creators
start getting codes and people start
playing it and realizing hey this is
this is pretty fun yeah H and then it
starts to slowly gain an audience the
game releases and starts selling like
crazy and then this is now where the
eyes of the cuz I feel like when a game
does well it's it's it does whatever but
then when a game does well to the point
where people who don't care about games
are star to look at it that's when stuff
starts to happen and obviously it is
worryingly similar to not just Pokemon
but a lot of games um for example you
open a chest it sounds very similar to
breath of the wild you discover a new
location very similar to breath of the
wild you fight monsters feels very
similar to Monster Hunter it's like an
AI generated game but yeah and it looks
well cuz it's it's got that Unreal
Engine look okay okay it's got this
Unreal unal Engine five right I think
this one yes so it's got this is like
and the problem is there a lot of asset
flips get put into those type of engines
so this kind of has a bad stigma so it
does look kind of bad but it's very very
very similar to Pokemon Aus right but
then there's some locations that look
like they've ripped it out of Elden ring
there's some places that I mean and then
it started this whole discourse then of
where because it was such a popular
thing this Twitter kind of it's and also
because you have to remember now people
get paid for having tweets that get seen
a lot that's the which is which is
probably the worst thing that Twitter
could have ever done I firmly believe
that incentivizing people to get views
on Twitter and not just like have a
discourse but like actively reward money
because then that means people there's
no there's no kind of um you're not like
holding yourself accountable for any
reason because there's no before it was
just your it was just your platform it
was like but now it's like there are
people out there who have no no desire
to have any kind of shame or be affected
by that it's purely like how do I make
as much money as possible and and the ad
revenue is [__] by the way I got paid
like $19 last month from X uh got yeah
you you could sign up for it I was
curious I I have as well I think I think
the most I got paid in a month paid all
of December I got $19 I I think I think
December I got paid yeah some like
$25 basically what ended up happening is
that people were starting to look at it
and people noticed that it looked very C
just like held up with the fact that
we're getting wait you guys are getting
paid I got like $19 we got pocket change
from El I got I got one Uber eat yeah it
was like so obviously you look at these
and you see okay wow these look there is
some kind of inspiration whether it's
plagiarism or not became a huge argument
and that was that was like the day one
argument was is this copying Pokemon too
much day two argument was they're using
AI because the Japanese Creator was kind
of uh was pretty vocal about uh being
somewhat supportive uh of some projects
but there's no proof that there's AI in
the game but of course Twitter ran with
it and started saying that kind of stuff
whether or not there is or not there
might be by the time this game comes out
by the time this video comes out they
might be proven that there is but the
point it was is that I guess and then a
lot of people got annoyed that it was
kind of being unfairly accused of being
using Ai and maybe stealing for example
some mesh models but then there was some
someone later admitted the guy who had
compared the meshes between a Pokemon
and a pal he had resized or kind of done
something there was this whole weird
thing where everyone was arguing
different arguments all at the same time
and then there was a a fan base of
people who were like I don't care what
the [__] they did as long as they make
Nintendo make a fun game CU this [__] is
way more fun than any Nintendo game and
so then there was this argument going on
and it's kind of become just absolute
[__] show where everyone is shouting
different things into the void and
different people are feel like they
should defend different things um and
the ultimate question is like does it
but but it's a fun game and that's the
worst part of it there we go how's the
game done and dusted and the worst part
is that I think that they are definitely
I mean from a personal perspective they
definitely feels way too close to to
Pokemon and certain things I think the
only argument I that is kind of valid in
this instance at least for me personally
is the comparison between Pokemon games
right in the sense that like you know as
a Pokémon fan myself I think this game
being so successful and it being
compared to Pokémon I think is a good
wake up call for Nintendo that's what a
lot of people arguing but a lot of
people like yeah you can you can say
that without arguing that like no you
can't because this is Nintendo we're
talking about would you say the let's
say the feel and the you know feeling of
plagiarism or like cuz there's always a
question between plagiarism yeah I'm
inspiration I'm playing it and it feels
uncomfortably close like you even like
breath of the wild like but then again
it's the same question of cuz I I
remember this is it plagiarism or is it
inspiration no cuz I I remember this
kind of discussion happening when genin
first if you if it's it's if if you
think that this is like plagiarizing for
example like breath of the wild then I
guess you'd it would have to be the it's
the the same level as genin of like but
then like open world games that you can
explore that's not something you can
plagiarize is it like a very similar
style and approach to how breath of the
wild did it yes I think so but the same
way that genin is and again I'm not
trying to defend this game there were
open wall games before birth of the W
I'm not trying to defend this game but
um like I think cuz it's the Pokemon
is way too close it's way way way way
too close yeah cuz like I'm looking just
like at some of these pictures and I'm
looking at some of these monsters and
I'm like oh that looks like that Pokemon
that looks like that looks like Lucario
the [__] there's a one that looks like
ret up there there's just some things
that they did that just baffles me why
they did the exact like Lea do you know
what this looks like um like you know
sometimes you're browsing on YouTube or
some [__] site you shouldn't be on
you see this ad of this weird mobile
game that get advertised
you know what I mean the one that looks
like a Pokemon game no no it could be
like any mobile like any weird mobile
game or it's like a [__] maybe it's a
league ripoff or maybe it's a Pokemon
ripoff a something ripoff and you're
like there is no way this game exists
and then you look into it and it's just
like oh this is just a build or whatever
but it kind of feels like the creators
have just looked at all the games they
like and just taken every single aspect
from every game they like and shoved it
into one but also maybe kind of copied
the style of all those things a little
too much like like I was mentioning
earlier there's some things they copied
too much which I think were just
completely unnecessary to copy um like
when you when you catch a a mon or Pal
or whatever you want to call it a I I
call them mons cuz I refus to call them
pal because it reminds me too much of
Chris Chan and I don't like calling them
cuz he calls everyone Pals um I think
that's a you problem yeah it is abely a
problem like the ball when you throw it
it Wiggles three times you could have
just not done that like why did you hear
it's like if you wanted to avoid the
plagiarism accusations why would you
make it so that so many little things
even just the fact you have to throw a
ball-shaped thing in order to catch it
as well I mean it's kind of it's kind of
hard and I get that's kind of
unavoidable but um at least change the
shape you know make it a cube or
something and like I don't think little
things like that would have been bad if
they hadn't have had so many designs
that are too closely inspired but then a
lot of people argued that then the
designs are inspired Pokemon designs are
inspired from yo-kai or mythology and
dragon real animals or real animals even
like people were arguing that the sheeps
look too same to the Pokémon sheep
people like it's a [__] sheep dog
which I agree with um and I think that I
think you can have the same conversation
of the sheep don't aren't a [__] copy
but hey that Lucario looks awfully a lot
like the Lucario well I mean I'm I'm I'm
just looking at this right go to the top
image like that third one there that
straight up looks like Leafeon yeah
absolutely like it's not even like I
think I think you can say that they
copied they not copied but ins even the
color palette is exactly the same as
Leaf some of the things are I I think
even if there is no legal battle here
right I think as a as a consumer you can
be like yeah this feel a little too
close but at the same time Pokemon fans
are so starved for a good [__] game
that I think they are just rejoicing at
the fact that they basically get to get
the game they wanted I I agree look as a
weird yeah I think as a Pokemon fan I
think this game becoming successful is
great for the Pokemon Community because
it is putting pressure I think or I'd
like to hope it is putting pressure
until Nintendo SU I think it's putting
pressure on Nintendo to be like hey make
a [__] good game but I don't think
that that has to mean that the company's
success is uh we should be super uh ah
it's so tough cuz I think that statement
can exist whilst also being like hey you
guys took a little too much well I think
like objectively like what this proved
uh you know is there is a huge gap in
the market you know there is I I don't
think I mean okay people are getting mad
because this game got popular of course
and I don't think there would be this
entire discourse around it if this game
wasn't breaking records left right and
Center if this if this had FedEd into
security no one would give a [__] yeah
and I think the reason this is breaking
records Left Right Center is because
there is a clear Gap in the market of
what people want in their video games we
just want we just want a Pokémon game in
Unreal Engine 5 that's what we've been
it was like put together by a bunch of
Japanese students and one of them was
like a comini worker student who was
like oh yeah I can make guns and he just
made the guns and apparently the reason
they added guns to the game was because
they said Americans like to shoot things
and I proven right I'm inclined to agree
with them because there's just like
[__] be thing I mean I I just
unlocked that Gatling gun uh and yeah
you literally can just gun down these
things uh and it's it's insane and it's
very fun I I think all the clips I've
seen of power world it just you know you
know it's it's a game that okay there's
this thing about plagiarism taking
things from different games it just
seems like a game that hits every single
gamer Instinct you could ever put have
in one single game the B building is
really fun you have a base that you
build and you essentially make a factory
base building cute monsters and when you
catch them it's not like in you know
it's not like in uh in Pokemon where you
catch these thing and you only use like
the six in your party you make them work
you put them to work in your base and
like you make them mine you make them
cut wood you make them make food you do
all my slaves yeah it's like it liter
literally was this a [__] EA Sim you
can also catch people I don't know if
you knew this uh you catch people so you
can actually make real slaves you can
catch people you can sell them for money
and you can make them work for free wait
I I think I think minut got a reminds me
of something you could also butcher the
Pokemon is this plagiarism you can also
butcher the people and the Pokemon for
resources uh as well holy [__] I call
them Pokemon but yeah you
know wow is nothing like Pokemon yeah I
mean it yeah it just seems like a game
where I mean look at that thing that
just [__] it's it's a car crash of
different genres and different and it's
also so buggy it's so [__] funny you
just you'll hit an enemy sometime they
just fly away and you're like okay how
many hours have you put into it like 40
I'm like nearly done with it nearly like
I've nearly got everything but what's
also great is that like you could just
have like five of your friends come just
[__] B come in the world and [__]
chill
out which is what they what they try to
do Monster Hunter esque raid where
you're all trying to catch this one
thing and it might have like a 1% chance
but you have to make the balls as well
you can't buy them you have to make them
so you have to you have to like really
manage your resources and again that was
something Pokemon tried to do with the
newest game and it just completely
[__] failed well arus felt so like
kind of well even Violet and Scarlet
with the multiplayer segment it was just
so like unintuitive and the fact that
that cuz it's on Steam I can literally
just be like hey Joe join my world pop
you're in you're in two seconds yeah and
you can join anytime there's no weird
kind of restrictions and it's and you
can also they allow you to adjust all
the settings of the server so if you
want to get XP way faster you can do it
if you want to catch stuff easier if you
want to get more drops if you want to
like creative mode yeah there's like
there's like raids on your base you can
turn them off so while you're out they
might come and raid your base quickly
get back and save your base from being
demolished it's really [__] cool like
there it's a like such a cool game idea
that is kind of unfortunately many
mechanics point it's unfortunately has
this cloud of did it copy too much um
and it's it you know it's kind of you
think most people care about that no no
I I think there is this unfortunate lack
of caring from consumers that don't care
about how their art is made and how it's
consumed um and I think it's a shame but
it's also how it's always been the
consumer rarely cares about how art is
made they just want it made and it's
it's almost like shatting at a brick
wall hoping that the consumer will care
about where their art comes from yeah
you know there are some people who look
look at a painting or look at a 3D model
of a of a a game they'll look at this
you know like Elden ring you might look
at a boss and like someone might look at
that and think holy [__] the amount of
work that must have g into design must
have model animate Rigg this thing must
have been absolutely painstaking and
must and a lot of people have interest
learning that and other people do not
give a [__] and they just think that
this thing gets made and it's made cuz
it got made and they don't realize that
maybe a boss character took thousands of
Collective hours and painstaking work to
make it come to life like that is kind
of sounds like the anime Community
doesn't it it's same as we have proven
time and time again with with the
animator situation consumers do not give
a [__] how the thing gets made as long
as it gets made as long as the end
product is good and it is so unfortunate
because I I think that I'd love for this
wall to coexist where we could have
everyone care about how the art is made
you know and I think to I watch kaon did
I have a moral obligation to not do that
I don't know it's weird like I don't
know where I don't know what I shouldn't
shouldn't do all I know is that it's bad
and I we want it to change so much so
that every single time my [__] little
pals are walking away everyone's like oh
it's a mappa studio in there like that's
become synonymous now with like horrible
working conditions like it's a joke now
like what is the what like what is the
they fail to realize that still an
actual massive problem that is outside
of that immediate thing as well I guess
that's why it's so hard to really get
invested in in this cuz you don't know I
don't know what the right stance is to
take even with what you describe with
power I don't even know what the problem
is not not like I don't know what the
core problem I don't know what like the
singular problem is cuz it seems like
there are multiple problems being and
everyone's fighting a different thing
and you're like and at the end of the
day consumer is going to see that [__]
show going on this one little side of
the interet and be like [__] this [__]
I'm just going to play the game yeah and
at the end of the day the power world
creators are just raking in the money
from the amount of hyp 200 million in
SES so far the second most concurrent
players of any steam game ever um it's
it's the the the success of this game is
something we've never seen before yeah
this is truly like on another level um
and it's frustrating as being like in
our position as well cuz I want to make
sure that you know with our platform and
what I'm doing is that we're sending out
the right message there and that that we
we care about artists and how artist
made I think it's important to care
about how artist made but I don't I
don't know as somebody who is in this
weird kind of commentary kind of not in
the process but a consumer and a lot of
people's viewing point of how like the
where this like a lot of people might
experience the art through me
interacting with it in some sense how do
I have a responsible way of sharing that
I don't know I how do how do you talk
about Jud kaon without thing right it's
difficult as you said like you know some
people are obviously going to care about
the underlying problems that are
legitimate problems but it's also very
difficult to try and convince people on
how they should think or you know what
stance they should take because this is
the internet everyone's [__]
opinionated they're not going to budge
just because someone told them that they
should think a certain way you know but
there's nothing unfortunately there's
nothing we can do about that yeah it's
also a shame cuz I I feel like sometimes
I feel like man I feel like um I
sometimes have the wrong mindset on this
as well where I think maybe I'm part of
the problem when I'm consuming this
anime and I think that but it's really
[__] good and how do I change how do
I change my perspective on that cuz I
don't know like I like I I'm watching
this thing and I I'm and I hear about
these stories and I want to know how the
[__] do I what is the best thing to do
here I don't know and how do I change my
mind about how I feel about this how do
I feel def about this media I personally
you should
uh worry less about what other what
other people perceive you because I'm
sure we might have said something in
here that would have offended some
people but you get to a point and at
least I had this realization yeah you
get to a point when you realize you know
people look at us with a big reach but
even with a reach are big we can only we
can only do so much and it's it's a it's
a it's an unwinable game of just always
being able to figure out what to do what
is the right thing to do about a certain
topic there are some certain topics we
know more about there are some certain
topics we don't know more about what
I've come to value is an acting change
that I have control of there are some
things where it's frustrating because
you feel like it's out of your control
and you want there to be changed but
there's just no control there and the
more the more I realize what I can
control and what I can't control the
more like with power world I can't
[__]
control I can't [__] control and
there is this argument about is this is
it ethical to consume or not and at the
end of the day i' like personally like
if you choose to consume it or don't
consume it personally I don't I don't
know how much of a big difference you
can make yeah also we're in the middle
of it so it could be in 5 years from now
there might be a
clear you know consensus yeah we're too
far into the the gray zone of this right
now where we don't know if there's an
actual correct right or wrong one thing
that that pisses me off sometimes when
I'm I'm like like playing a [__]
video game and someone's like hey you
should talk about this thing and I'm
like I'm what do you want me to say yeah
I I am like I'll talk about it if I want
to talk about it like I I like what is
me G to do talking about this thing to
this audience like who already have
already probably made up their own mind
have their own personal opinions about
it it's like me I am like the McDonald's
equivalent of like a on the Michelin
star Chef world like I'm at the bottom
of this chain of producing slop
essentially come to notice people who
ask that kind of [__] to you uh they
don't actually want to hear your opinion
they are either sitting on either side
of the fence and they want to hear
someone that they admire and get
validation from them really I feel like
sometimes people just want you to agree
with them and say the thing they agree
with well no that's exactly what it is
and it's like you know it's like if
you're sitting on one side of the fence
or the other and like I go up to you for
example and say like hey can you talk
about this issue which side do you agree
with if you agree with my side then
great the ship is sailing if I don't
agree with if I don't agree with
whatever you say oh there's another
reason to hate you you know and it's
like well then what the [__] either way
I'm not winning because I'm throwing
myself into this conversation that I
didn't want to throw myself into that's
why you haven't heard anything from him
yet if I wanted to join the conversation
you didn't have to ask me I would have
said something it feels like you know
with especially with something like
Twitter or modern uh problems it seems
like everyone needs to have an opinion I
think everyone just needs I I I think
the world can actually you know
move on more if you a lot of people
realize you don't have to have an
opinion about everything you know you
can do your best to be educated but
we're all [__] human you know there's
only so much we can intake and so much
we can emotionally get invested in and
care about you know there are some
issues that unfortunately I have no
personal investment in you know as much
as uh you know because in this day and
age it seems like I need to be invested
in everything going on all around the
world it's hot uh and no one person can
do that I don't think the human brain
can truly comprehend this many issues
and not go [__] crazy or not go
depressed absolutely unfortunately so
it's been yeah it's been a weird game
and it's kind of made a lot of
interesting conversation